i
[Música]
a
es el país del mundo que tiene más
empleadas domésticas según datos de la
organización internacional del trabajo
son cerca de 7 millones de mujeres que
muchas veces viven en condiciones
precarias y reciben salarios bajos
además en la última década hubo varios
rescates de mujeres que estaban
trabajando en condiciones de esclavitud
precisamente para mejorar sus
condiciones de trabajo la ex presidenta
dilma rousseff aprobó una ley que les
daba derecho a un contrato formal y
futuramente a una jubilación digna esta
ley fue muy criticada por las élites
brasileñas e incluso hay analistas que
creen que esta fue la última gota que
precipitó finalmente el impeachment de
dilma rousseff durante la pandemia este
sector profesional ha sido muy afectado
se calcula que cerca de 2 millones de
empleadas domésticas perdieron su
trabajo y también su sustento principal
además hay que recordar que la primera
víctima mortal del cobi de río de
janeiro fue precisamente una doméstica
que se contagio a través de su jefe que
había vuelto enfermo
a italia
[Música]
en argentina existe desde 2013 una ley
específica que regula el trabajo
doméstico cuyo objetivo ha sido intentar
reducir el nivel de informalidad en el
sector sin embargo en el país tres de
cada cuatro de las trabajadoras de casas
particulares se encuentran en la
informalidad según la organización
internacional del trabajo hablo en
femenino porque según la misma entidad
del 95 por ciento de los 14 millones de
trabajadores del sector son mujeres
mujeres a las que la pandemia de ccoo y
19 afectó especialmente más allá del
riesgo sanitario desde el inicio de la
cuarentena en marzo de 2020 sólo se les
permitió seguir trabajando a aquellas
que se desempeñaban en tareas de cuidado
de personas sólo más adelante pudieron
volver a trabajar aquellas contratadas
para otras actividades como limpieza en
la ciudad de buenos aires por ejemplo
fue recién en octubre de 2020 como
consecuencia hubo una caída en el empleo
y en las condiciones de trabajo de las
empleadas de casas particulares en
argentina todo en el ya crítico contexto
de la pandemia de kobe 19
[Música]
en venezuela la situación de las
empleadas domésticas durante la pandemia
del cobi 19 ha tenido dos caras una
parte de este sector ha perdido sus
empleos debido a que algunos patronos
decidieron que las trabajadoras no
vinieran a sus casas para evitar
contagios otros no pudieron seguir
pagándoles los salarios y las
despidieron algunas domésticas que
perdieron sus empleos se han cambiado de
rubro y ahora se dedican a las ventas en
la economía informal sin embargo de otra
parte de este sector que mantuvo sus
empleos y debido a la dolarización en el
país están percibiendo sus salarios
entre 200 y 400 dólares un sueldo por
encima de los 2 dólares mensuales que
puede ganar un médico las trabajadoras
del hogar tienen beneficios en la ley
venezolana laboral como son las
prestaciones sociales y bonificaciones
de fin de año entre otros no obstante no
existe ningún apartado que les dé
protección económica durante épocas de
emergencia como la que se vive
actualmente en tiempos de pandemia las
empleadas domésticas afectadas no han
recibido ayuda de ninguna
intergubernamental ni social